yesterday was a dark day for British
policing and the Metropolitan Police as
an officer admitted being responsible
for a monstrous campaign of abuse
Mr Speaker I am sure the whole house
will want to join me in expressing my
sympathy to the victims and thank them
for their courage in coming forward
it is intolerable for them to have
suffered as they have
they were manipulated and isolated and
subjected to horrific abuse
for anyone to have gone through such
torment is harrowing
but for it to have happened at the hands
of someone they entrusted to keep people
safe is almost beyond comprehension
the victims have shown extraordinary
strength and courage their testimonies
were essential in ensuring that Carrick
faces Justice for his crimes it's thanks
to them that this vile Predator has been
taken off our streets and the public are
safer
as a result
Mr Speaker the police perform a unique
and critical function in our society
every day
thousands of decent hard-working police
officers perform their duties with the
utmost professionalism
they feel pride in putting on their
uniform and want only the best for the
communities that they serve
I know that they will share our
Collective disgust that a fellow officer
could be responsible for such a
Despicable betrayal of everything that
they stand for
it's imperative that this cannot happen
again
and so I'm grateful for lady eilish
angelini's assurance that she will look
at this heinous case as part of her
inquiry
Mr Speaker from the moment I became
homes secretary I've made clear that
things have to change
public trust is precious
our model of policing by consent connect
cannot cannot work effectively without
it
I discussed this case yesterday with the
commissioner of the Metropolitan Police
Sir Mark Rowley and I'm encouraged by
the action that he has taken so far with
his team to root out officers who are
not fit to wear the badge
this effort is being spearheaded by a
new anti-corruption and abuse command
but there is still some way to go to
ensure that the force can command the
trust of the people that it serves
it is vital that the Metropolitan Police
and other forces double down on their
efforts to root out corrupt officers
this may mean more shocking cases come
to light in the short term
it's a matter of the utmost importance
that there are robust processes in place
to stop the wrong people joining the
police in the first place
which is why the government has invested
in improving recruitment processes and
supporting vetting as part of over three
billion pounds that we have provided for
the police uplift program
I expect this work to continue at PACE
and for all Chief constables to
prioritize delivery of the
recommendations made by the police
inspectorate's recent report on vetting
counter-corruption and misogyny
it's now for the Metropolitan Police to
demonstrate that they have an effective
plan in place to rapidly improve their
vetting processes
much of the impetus for change must come
from within policing but this government
will continue leading from the front
as I've been clear we are bringing
forward part two of the Angelini inquiry
to make recommendations on how forces
can improve culture and tackle the root
causes of police criminality and
misconduct
the inquiry was established by the then
Home Secretary my right humble friend
the member for Whitton and I pay tribute
to her for her commitment and Leadership
on these critical issues
yeah
as well as ensuring vetting processes
are watertight there must be fair and
effective arrangements for dealing with
those who behave or act in a wholly
unacceptable way while serving
baroness Casey has recently identified
concerns with the misconduct and
dismissals process within the
Metropolitan Police
it takes too long it doesn't command the
confidence of police officers and it's
procedurally burdened bureaucracy and
process appear to have prevailed over
ethics and Common Sense
that's why I've announced an internal
review into police dismissals the
reviews terms of reference are being
published today
Mr Speaker
this case will rightly throw a spotlight
once again on women's safety
no one should suffer abuse or feel
frightened or harassed whether they are
at home out and about or online
we are taking concerted action to
prevent violence against women support
victims and survivors relentlessly
pursue perpetrators and strengthen the
system as a whole
on rape specifically we are focused on
delivering improvements across the board
so that victims get the support they
deserve and cases are pursued rigorously
from report to court
there have been some important steps
forward since the publication of the
rape review in 2021 the number of
referrals and charges have increased
nationally while new operating models
for the investigation and prosecution of
rape are being developed through
operation ceteria Mr Speaker
none of us can undo the suffering of
carricks victims
but I can assure the house that this
government will not shy away from
challenging the police to meet the
standards we all expect of them
change must happen and as Home Secretary
I will do everything in my power to
ensure that it does
I commend this statement to the house